hi guys it's silver ed again and I hoped
that within now and a few episodes I'm
going to be able to finish this park
finally I mean I've spent when once this
is finished I've probably spent about 25
episodes in this but every episode takes
more than two hours to record if you
consider the fact that time lapses
actually take very long I think I speed
them up about six times or something
probably even more so actually a lot of
work went into this and I'm really
looking forward to making a video of
this but before I can do that there are
a few things I have to finish this area
of the park and I've no idea what I'm
going to do here I mean nothing would be
kind of boring but there's not enough
space to make a little lake or something
like that so I don't know probably I'll
probably just make a little hill or
something with trees and I need to
finish this part I really need to do
something with this maybe even and a
flat ride or something this needs to be
fixed need a fence over here need to
finish the back sides of the buildings
here and then all that's left to do is
the foliage maybe some groundwork
actually some terraforming stuff and
then I'm finished and that won't take
too long so let's get right into this
railroad
there is no place in our moment in
history where the standards day
it's here
railroad
well then apart from foliage and a few
details this is it there's nothing else
I still need to do I mean I've done
everything except for just foliage maybe
a bit of rock work here and there and as
I said before terraforming and many
people well this annoys many people and
of course I'm going to finish these
walls and make that it's a bit of a
boring job I'm not looking forward to it
but that's all stuff that I'm going to
record but not really I'm not going to
record it you see I'm not going to make
another time-lapse video of this park
this season though I will continue with
that afterwards but I'm going to do
probably one more episode in which I'll
just go through the progress of doing
foliage and other stuff that I really
can't do while recording because the
problem is that there's just terrible
lag right now you can't really see it
but that's because there's barely any
foliage and experience tells me that
once you start doing the foliage your
games going to crash yeah that's the
reason why I'm not recording while doing
the foliage so sorry for that guys but
I'll keep you up to date during the
episode just from time to time and show
some you show some of the progress that
I'm making so you can you guys can have
somewhat of a preview trailer kind of
thing a teaser of what this park is
eventually going to look like and what
the final video is going to look like
because as you might be able to tell
this does not look very finished but the
thing is as soon as you start doing
foliage and the foliage is finished then
it's finally done because other than the
foliage there's nothing else that really
needs to be done okay so well there's
some terraforming stuff like I said
before way too many times and there's
these buildings but whatever who really
cares so I'm going to end this episode
and start working on the end of this